[Music]
what we're supposed to be doing here is
not simply a climb in the mountain the
scientific objectives that we're doing
here with global climate change are
really what define our expedition and
will allow us to bring back some
information that will be pertinent to
everybody on earth
it's really a perspective on man's
relationship with the natural world and
it's critical that we understand that we
don't inherit our resources from our
ancestors we borrow it from our children
this environment is uncontrollable it's
hostile it doesn't care whether we're
successful on our expedition whether we
climb it whether we get our scientific
data or not
the mountain is just going to move as
its going to move and we have to be
prepared to to deal with that as best as
possible
the mountains like a mirror that holds
you and your performance up to you there
are days where you feel like you're
struggling to put one foot in front of
the other that's the same as it was back
in the 1920s same as it is today
we have a great team of Sherpa we have a
great team of scientists but ultimately
we're pretty puny in the face of a
mountain that doesn't always tolerate
humanity so well it's really quite a
daunting task for our team but we're up
for it
but the winds in excess of 50 miles an
hour snow in your face all the time
trying to breathe in air and do some
complicated assembly we have the team
here to achieve and succeed in all those
types of scientific objectives but also
to be able to tell the story
what's our ten-year plan what's our
20-year plan where do we need to be to
be protecting these places the story
that we can bring back will be
incredibly compelling and a show what an
expedition in 2019 is all about
[Music]
you
[Music]